sometimes like the oil will make a
little
you know pattern on the other side art
you're getting the oil off your face and
you're making a what's that called a
what's that rorschach it's like a
like a rorschach with the oil on your
face
that's gross
what's up everyone my name is leslie
odom jr and these are my essentials
this is my trusty bose revolver
speaker i travel quite a bit
and it is the perfect size for a single
room
be it a bathroom bedroom a hallway it's
just a
really powerful little personal speaker
the sound is fantastic
i was away on vacation recently and i
didn't bring
uh when they send me mixes to listen to
stuff i say they're my producers
my collaborators they want me to listen
to it on like very specific headphones
and i didn't bring them
so i listened to the mixes on the bulls
revolve and it's
it's the strangest thing but you get the
surround
sound you really can hear the detail and
you really feel like the sound
wraps around you to your lantern lights
the way
you put your tunes on and they light the
way
[Music]
oil absorbing strips
after a long night hanging out after a
show
or something like that you know like the
sweat turns to oil
and like i just get like real shiny up
around here so these
are essential my face gets
very oily ever since i was a teenager
these haven't been around my whole life
i was probably in high school when these
really became like so widely available
and i've tried lots of different
versions of these like
clean and clear are kind of one of the
most widely available ones so it doesn't
matter where i am in the country or in
the world i can always find these
so like there's a little sticky thing on
there that helps it
just it's gonna be gross when you see
how much oil i have in my face
this is my trusty hype mic before
this moment that we found ourselves in i
mean i was almost traveling to these
studios and
all this you know big equipment very
expensive equipment all over the place
and now
i do it on this even like little casual
videos
if i'm doing them for social if i'm
doing them for like
you know wishing somebody happy birthday
or something like that
this makes everything sound better
actually i'm on an animated show
called central park and we have been
recording from home
and so i'm recording an actual
cartoon but i get to make it on this
little mic right here
you take it to wherever you are in the
house it has an attachment it'll attach
to your computer
or your phone you can plug your
headphones
directly into the mic it's a really
impressive little thing people have been
very impressed with the quality that you
can get from the hype
mic so certainly now this is an
essential i travel with it
all right this one this one's gonna get
me in some trouble
this is a book of photographs by the
brilliant unique harmony corrine
for gucci but i've made this
my journal i hope harmony's not upset i
am a guy that that likes to journal i
have
like i like it so much when i find a
cool journal
i'll buy it even if i don't need it and
just sort of like i have i literally
have a chest
of journals in my house for like what
you know one day when i finish one i'll
grab another one
but i've never had a journal quite like
this
the thing that's great about it is that
you can
open it and even if you're like
searching for something to write
you can get inspiration from another
artist
i journal through projects
because usually if i'm in creative
process the thoughts and the inspiration
comes quickly and so i need to have a
book close by to write
let me do this while i was making my
record mister
finish the task don't you dare give up
you don't have the right god needs some
warriors out here
god needs some folks who are willing and
courageous enough to finish
what they've started especially after he
starts them
i think inspiration comes from the
divine
you know and so when you are inspired to
create something
you've got to finish it no matter what
it takes you have to finish the task
so i needed to hear that and so i wrote
it down
when somebody finds your work when
another artist
finds your work and like makes it
personal to them
i would be flattered i hope harmony is
too
it's my little journal my cardigan
because i haven't had the best track
record of holding on to my things
i don't get really sentimentally
attached to a lot of objects
so i bought a sweater in my 20s from
this shop on beverly i don't even
remember the shop but i spent like 300
bucks on this sweater
double-breasted hand-knit black sweater
it went with everything
i loved the sweater and i lost it i have
mourned the loss of that sweater for 10
years
so i bought this i did the research and
i bought myself
this ralph lauren cardigan
only 10 short years later to replace my
double breasted black
hand that's what it i wanted something
that was gonna be
durable something that would last i
wanted some style
it's not everybody's cup of tea but like
something that i put on
you know you might get a couple
compliments wearing it and
i wanted something unique so this one i
really loved
the tie i really love the waist tie
shawl collar
come on it's not bad i wait until the
first
sign of a chill and like oh it feels
like
cardigan weather i wonder if i oh oh
there's my
shawl collared ralph lauren aging
sweater in the back of the closet maybe
it's
time to get my sweater and a cup of hot
chocolate
these are my lgr sunglasses
i will admit to you that i spent
way too much money in my 20s on
sunglasses
the first time i ever got my hands on
like a chunk of change
i went to melrose and i bought myself
some sunglasses real sunglasses one day
i was telling my friend
who's chastising me about how much i'd
spent on sunglasses
i was like you know but i'm a collector
i have this collection of some people
are allowed to collect things and i
collect sunglasses he was like okay
great so
where's your collection because i lost
every single one
of those glasses that i bought until
these i've held on to these
longer than i have any pair of
sunglasses they are my favorite
i would be really sad if i lost them
it's a company called
lgr it's a little italian brand
i just love them i wear them when i
perform sometimes because
i sometimes can feel it more or find it
more
when my eyes are closed and these
somehow
make my eyes never closed especially
when i'm first starting out
a show a concert like if i can wear
these
it helps me relax a little bit
bevel skin care i've never been skin
care guy i've never taken
terrific care of my skin i'm ashamed to
say
but i have started now i did a movie
with regina king
in new orleans called one night in miami
four black men
are the leads of this movie and so bevel
sent over the skin care
for all of us while we were shooting the
movie i wear a prosthetic nose in the
movie a couple of the guys had to shave
regularly and bevel started as a shaving
company
specifically designed for black men and
men of color
because that's a tricky thing for us and
then they moved on to skin care and
other things and this it's just my
favorite
skin care line that i've ever used
face wash they have an exfoliating
toner and a moisturizing
face gel i do think it improves the look
of my skin
after having used it for a while it also
feels nice
to be giving a little bit of attention
to a part of my body that i
lean on a lot not that i'm some
you know supermodel or anything but you
know like we depend on our skin
quite a bit right my skin's been with me
a long time
attention must be paid you know i mean
it deserves a little bit of
tlc every now and again the company is
called saint rita parlour and this scent
is called
rita's car this is the scent that i
share much to her great annoyance i
share the scent with my wife she bought
it there's a little boutique that we
love here called
carl's atelier a unisex
scent but i happen to think it's more
masculine i would tell you about it i
would describe it to you but
i think that they do a better job they
say
notes leather vanilla musk tobacco
rare coins and fresh cut foliage
come on rare coins nicolette keeps
it on her and her side of the on her
side of the closet
and every now and again when i see it i
feel i feel good i just
[Applause]
[Music]
you know real quick just love it
books books are an essential item i
don't travel without them i don't
go anywhere without them you can get
lost in a great book man
you know somewhere waiting around
instead of scrolling through your phone
if i have
a book or two in my backpack i can get
lost in a book instead of
on social media or something like that i
gravitate toward
biographies autobiographies and
motivational
books you know generally so this one i
brought some of my
some of my most essential books this one
i ripped the cover off because i'm a
little embarrassed by it
you know if i'm reading it on the train
or something in new york i don't want
everybody to know that i'm reading
true and false by david mamet if you
happen to be an actor it is my favorite
book on
acting when i was doing hamilton i'd
like to say
lynn's script was my old testament
and this was my new testament or vice
versa but this was like
definitely a part of the bible of that
performance for me
just simplifies the whole mystery of
acting there's days where you know you
just do the same scene again and again
you want to be able to reproduce your
work or or
or find a zone find a pocket where you
can count on
a certain kind of quality in what you're
doing just ma'am it just makes it so
simple
essentially like it begins and ends at
the writing and if anything comes up for
you if you are inspired
genuinely in any way just don't deny
that
don't block that don't stop that and
that is your responsibility full stop
it's a great book this is my favorite
poetry book
i found this book at a book sale while i
was in college
i paid two whole dollars for this book
and it just changed my life you know
it's written by my favorite poet
john hodgin but it's not like i know a
ton of poets
you know i just happen to like this guy
and this book especially right now
in this country a book i think that is
just
essential to understanding where we are
and how we got here
is called we were eight years in power
by mr
kanahasi coach essential reading list
this is my favorite luggage that i've
ever bought
from a company called away has a
battery for inevitably
when my phone dies at the airport or
the train station or whatever it's
affordable
but durable looks smart
you know fashionable and uh
super functional too oh the other thing
i wanted to tell you
if you are packing like get yourself
a bunch of these a bunch of these bags
because
it helps you section out your thing so
you can put all your pants in here
all your shirts in here your underwear
going here it just
organizes everything and makes
everything simpler i've learned to be a
light packer
i kind of take pride in that i kind of
take pride in how little luggage
i can travel with my wife and i got
three of these each so i have this one
slightly larger slightly larger for the
big vacations for the family vacations
but yeah if i can just take this and a
book bag
i can get a weekend out of that so
my luck my luggage my luggage system
here
gq that's it my 10 essentials i'm leslie
odom jr thanks for letting me hang out
with you
and show you some of the objects i love
the most